I know clearly the Arctic Blast has
caused significant disruption right
across the country long stretches of the
M25 Motorway have been jammed drivers in
the south east are being asked by
national highways not to travel unless
they absolutely have to
people have been describing to Sky News
how they've been stuck in their cars
through the freezing night
in an absolute standstill for yeah over
here so
um yeah it's um it's pretty
disheartening
um I mean that's it the the UK were just
rubbish we are rubbish when the weather
gets extreme aren't we we really are bad
no so um I'm meant to be getting home
for Nottingham
um home to Nottingham so
um yeah maybe maybe I'll definitely get
home for Christmas maybe that's the plan
we've got a new plan
big problems at the airports as well at
both Gatwick and Stansted had to close
their runways yesterday to clear the
snow they are open again now but with
reduced flights and a huge backlog of
waiting passengers Travelers are being
wanted to check with their carrier
before leaving for the airport I would
like to speak to somebody finds themself
in well at Gatwick Airport Bethany
Wharton has been stranded there and she
joins us on the line and Bethany good to
talk to you and first things first where
were you supposed to be going
uh to Bali
to Bali and instead you're trapped at
Gatwick I mean how long have you been
there for I've been here around 17 hours
17 hours yes
what kind of communication have you
heard from from the airline and from the
uh from the airport have they given you
any idea of when you might be heading
off
um nothing so far
um we spoke to some staff
um when we came back through questions
yesterday they said to go back to your
airline just in the morning around eight
o'clock and they'll tell us some more
information but that's all we've heard
and we couldn't get any hotels last
night as everywhere was fully booked
everyone's in the same position everyone
has just been sleeping on the floor
so how many of you are though Bethany
who's traveling with you at the moment
I'm with my boyfriend at the moment
and how have you guys managed to call I
mean have you have you managed to grab
any sleep yourselves
um not really I've had a couple of hours
but everyone's in the same situation
there's lots of people children as well
and um everyone's just trying to get
some sleep but it's really cold as well
in here yeah I I can normally I can only
imagine I mean have you have you at
least been provided with some teas
coffees food anything like that
um no nothing
haven't had really any help from any
staff
um can't really find anyone to speak to
just been a bit of a nightmare so
Bethany was this you heading off for for
the Christmas period or is this just a
quick trip you were planning no no
I was moving to Australia
heading out to Australia
oh dear oh dear so what's what's this
going to do for your plans I mean if if
you can't get away today what what does
that necess what does that maybe mean
for well for the trip to Bali yeah so
our trip um we'll have to miss out parts
of our trip that we've already booked um
I've also had to cancel some things
we've already tried to book already
um I'm not sure if we'll get any money
back from the airline as um they said
they wouldn't even offer us
um money for a hotel for the night
is there is there any thought in your
mind of just jacking it and leaving the
airport going home and getting
yourselves warm and maybe getting some
get maybe getting some sleep
yes I did I did think that last night
before uh before I even tried to sleep
um
but
gonna try again today and then maybe
we'll we will have to go back
and I I suppose Bethany you must have
been looking forward to this trip for
for quite a long time yeah and obviously
we've already said bye to everyone at
home so
oh dear
um well look I I I will be keeping my
fingers crossed Bethany I mean moving to
Australia is it is a big old is a big
old trip in and of itself but but to
miss it on the barley leg um look well
stay warm and keep in touch and let let
us know if you manage to get on that
plane sometime today I hope you do
thank you very much thank you you take
care of Bethany
uh let's bring in Sky's Becky Cottrell
at Victoria Station in London uh
Victoria good to see it um what what is
the the state of play in terms of
Transport this morning Becky I mean I
know myself from from driving in this
morning the roads are absolutely
treacherous and the fact that people if
they can avoid driving to they really
should do but one of the public
transport aspect
well certainly if you're trying to get
the train you're likely to face problems
today particularly if you're here in the
Southeast or London I'm at London's
Victoria Station many of the lines here
suspended the companies that operate up
here south eastern Southern rail the
Gatwick Express they've all had problems
with snow on the tracks overnight as I
say having to cancel services today they
are trying to get them back up and
running but it's likely the disruption
will continue for much of the day and
it's of course not just the conditions
on the tracks that are the problem
they're also trying to put on
replacement bus services but if the
conditions on the road simply aren't
good enough then that is not going to be
possible either as you mentioned drivers
also facing a lot of problems we are
getting into Monday rush hour now and as
you said the advice in southeast simply
don't travel unless you absolutely have
to reports of drivers stuck on the roads
in the snow and and as they're trying to
clear that clearly some of the backlog
may clear but it's going to continue for
much of the day so really particularly
if you're here in the Southeast I would
stay home because you absolutely have to
travel
Becky thank you
[Music]